should be honest with you the worst part
was not the money that I did spend in
those courses the worst part was we're
gonna pull back the curtain I'm gonna
show you the exact system that Oksana
used to go from nothing to over five
hundred thousand dollars how would you
like to make ten thousand dollars per
month if you understand this one concept
you can make a full-time income from
home and if you don't believe me that's
completely fine you shouldn't when a guy
screams at you and YouTube
[Music]
[Music]
maybe we should address it though maybe
we should address it
you chose to be anonymous can you can
you explain why you chose to be
anonymous yeah it's [ __ ] embarrassing
to be honest with you it's [ __ ]
embarrassing
it's just when people because people
don't don't know what you was thinking
about when you was taking those
decisions how [ __ ] you are yeah let's
put it that way
I don't think out on the Year [ __ ] I
think you just believed people who
advertised falsely to you I just want
you to tell me your your story and what
happened to you I'm mostly gonna like
leave it to you to tell and specifically
I want to focus on like how much money
you spent
I mean why you paid them and then also
how that's impacted your life how much
money in courses a lot I mean I cannot
conscious I buy a lot of courses one of
them was given David
the other one was Alex Baker and some
other other courses basically the the
the most expensive one was Alex Baker
cause which cause I think 1,500 back
then how much how old are you right now
I am 22 22 cool basically they said it's
it's it's 5k to 6k derided spamming in
just courses why I did pay them
basically the overselling of the dream
and all those promises of yeah we have a
proven system that's gonna work for you
that's gonna make you money and stuff
like this let me ask you this how much
total have you spent chasing the dream
not just in courses but in all the
things they've told you to do if you
could kind of ballpark it for me just
give me a rough estimate let me tell you
just in marketing I mean in advertising
I did spend more than $13,000 just in
marketing marketing and and courses it
it's almost 20k
it's almost 20 K yeah did you achieve
the dream no no I didn't achieve that
dream and the reason why it was not
because I did not do exactly what they
did said it was not because I did not
apply apply everything to the courses no
I did just a lot of courses I did just a
lot of proven systems and stuff like
this
none of that church work to be honest
with you and yeah it's almost 20 K did
you have this kind of money when you
spent $20,000 no no I'm not that kind of
rich person I'm not like I'm not from a
very rich family or something like this
basically I am I was in the University
and in the same time I was working you
you sent me in your email that it got
you you were in debt and you lost your
job because of these marketing
opportunity our dreams yeah let me
explain this basically at the end when I
was start like losing a lot of money
losing a lot of money then I end up with
no money so the idea was to stop paying
because I stopped like stopping Iran to
stop doing some stuff so that I can save
that money to invest it again so because
of that I started getting in I I didn't
get in that because of this so basically
I did stop paying for example in rent
for more than five months I did stop I I
didn't I didn't hold on you start paying
rent for five months because you were
because of these gurus exactly yes
because yeah when I did spend all that
money I I did left with no money so I
did told myself I need to stop paying
rent so that I can invest that money in
marketing invest that money so that's
how I can so that I can succeed
basically yeah the fact that I did lost
my job which was my mistake why because
I was like you know what it doesn't work
it I need to concentrate on this so that
I can like give it 100% so that I can
succeed as fast
Passport but I end up losing that job
because of this mentality of I can do
anything to be clear though gurus
promote that mentality exactly not only
gurus gurus and also self-development I
have a lot of books like right here for
example this book I don't even want to
mention the name this book one of the
worst books ever did the secret ask
believe receive [ __ ] and the Think
and Grow Rich to be honest with you I
used to believe in all this shut I don't
believe in it anymore it's just a it's a
big scam it's a big and this tree the
the making money the nature of making
money and the nature of self-development
big [ __ ] it's a big scam everybody
is trying to scam you everybody tried to
cheat to take your money and the worst
thing to be honest with you the worst
part was not the money that I did spend
in those courses the worst part was the
road that me show you it's [ __ ]
[ __ ] because you go exactly the
wrong way and used I did spend 20k in
marketing and I did not lost that money
not because I was not having the
experience but because I was in the
wrong world the wrong road basically
that's why you waste time they teach you
the wrong things yeah yeah yeah yeah so
the 5k that I did spending in in all
those courses was not like the problem
the problem was I was in the role role
absolutely let me ask you this because I
think your stories are obviously I think
you hope and I hope that people see it
and they learn from it but what would
you tell what would you tell somebody if
they're thinking of investing in a
course if they're thinking of going down
this road if you could speak to yourself
I guess two three years ago what would
you say how would say [ __ ] stop don't
do it save the [ __ ] money and try to
stop a [ __ ] true business thank you
so much
I think we're gonna make this quick
thanks for watching guys if you have a
testimonial you'd like to come on like
this brave man did go ahead and either
send me an email send me a DM on Twitter
at coffee break underscore YouTube or
whitey or or you can just film a video
of yourself tell me how you were
impacted and send it to my email
straightaway you can do that too thanks
for watching guys
[Music]
[Music]